Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft.
Und ich begrüße alle zur 88. Ausgabe von Forschergeist.
Und wie schon beim letzten Mal möchten wir heute auf eine Nominierung für den deutschen Zukunftspreis 2021 eingehen.
Der mal ein ganz anderes Feld beackert als das im letzten Podcast der Fall war.
Hier geht es nämlich um, ja, man könnte sagen, um Botanik, aber auch um die Nachhaltigkeit in der Industrie.
Ist natürlich ein großes Thema und dementsprechend ist das auch hier im Zukunftspreis mit berücksichtigt worden.
Ja und es dreht sich alles um den Löwenzahn.
Und dazu begrüße ich meinen Gesprächspartner Dirk Prüfer.
Schönen guten Tag Herr Prüfer.
Schönen guten Tag.
Ja, ich bin nach Münster gefahren zu Ihnen.
Sie sind ja hier Professor für molekulare Biotechnologie der Pflanzen am Institut für Biologie und Biotechnologie der Pflanzen.
Alles sehr ausführlich formuliert und das Ganze im Rahmen der westfälischen Wilhelms-Universität in Münster.
Habe ich das so richtig wiedergegeben?
Das ist alles vollkommen korrekt.
Sehr schön, genau.
Und ja, wie lange sind Sie das schon?
Also ich bin seit 2005 in Münster Professor für molekulare Biotechnologie.
Davor habe ich diverse andere Stationen in meinem Lebenslauf gehabt.
Das ging von grundlegender Forschung wie Max-Planck-Institute bis hin eben zur Fraunhofer-Gesellschaft,
die dann wieder die angewandte Forschung macht, aber Professor bin ich seit 2005.
Und wie fing das alles an mit der Wissenschaft?
Ja, das ist eine lange Geschichte, vielleicht kann ich da ein bisschen weiter ausholen halt.
Gerne, immer.
Also die Grundlage wurde eigentlich damals in der Schule gelegt.
Ich bin so ein klassischer, wie sagt man heute so schön, Spätzünder gewesen.
Ich war also erst mal auf der Hauptschule und habe dann nach dem neunten Schuljahr eine Ausbildung gemacht bei Bayer als Chemikant.
Und war eigentlich total begeistert, weil ich dachte mir so, das ist so was Labor für mich, irgendwas mit Chemie zu machen.
Bin dann da hingegangen und hatte dann erst mal so U-Stahl feilen dürfen und das für ganze drei Monate.
U-Stahl?
U-Stahl, ja das macht viel Spaß.
Klingt jetzt nicht besonders chemisch.
Hat auch nicht viel damit zu tun.
Also das war eine lange Geschichte, die habe ich jetzt ganz kurz nur.
Und ich habe dann irgendwie gemerkt, das ist es nicht, da kannst du nicht bleiben.
Und hatte dann das große Glück, dass es in der Nähe ein Gymnasium gab, was den ersten Abiturjahrgang dann eben hatte.
Da bin ich dann da hingegangen und habe gefragt, ob es denn möglich wäre, da noch aufgenommen zu werden halt.
Da wurde mir gesagt, das können Sie gerne machen, Sie kommen von der Hauptschule, haben jetzt noch drei Monate später angefangen,
machen Sie es einfach mal, wenn Sie sitzen bleiben, dann machen wir es ein Jahr später noch mal.
Das Leibniz-Gymnasium Dormagen, also mein großer Dank an diese Schule.
Okay.
Weil das war eine unwahrscheinlich schöne Zeit.
Ich habe also eine Schule erlebt danach, ich dachte, das gibt es gar nicht, also unwahrscheinlich gut gefördert worden,
vor allem in den Naturwissenschaften auch durch die Lehrer, die es da gab.
Und habe es dann irgendwie geschafft, da durchzukommen.
Und dann war immer mein Traum gewesen, Luft- und Raumfahrttechnik zu machen.
Oh.
Obwohl ich in der Schule eigentlich Mathe und Physik waren jetzt nicht meine besten Fächer gewesen,
sondern das war eigentlich immer Biologie gewesen.
Ja dann habe ich Zivildienst gemacht, damals noch diese klassische Linie, also mit Verweigerung und diese Dinge.
Und habe dann Zivildienst im Krankenhaus gemacht.
Und hatte das große Glück, dass damals ein Professor von der Universität Aachen bei mir auf der Station lag
und der war Professor für Luft- und Raumfahrttechnik.
Und der hat mir dann relativ schnell und knapp vor Augen gehalten, dass das vielleicht nicht das richtige für mich wäre halt,
weil die Fragen, die er mir gestellt hat und was man nach einem Studium macht,
das ist also alles das, was man sich nicht unter Raumfahrttechnik vorstellt.
Also blieb dann die andere Schiene, Biologie, das habe ich dann auch gemacht, an der Uni Köln dann Biologie studiert.
War eine sehr schöne Zeit.
Ich finde auch, das sage ich meinen Studierenden heute immer, eine ganz andere Zeit halt.
Also wenn ich mir heute die Studien angucke, das ist schon so sehr verschult alles.
Die haben ja gar keine richtige Zeit zu studieren.
Und bin dann zu meiner Doktorarbeit an das Max-Planck-Institut für Pflanzenzüchtungsforschung in Köln gegangen.
Habe da promoviert über ein Pflanzenvirus.
Also auch Pflanzen haben Viren.
Vielleicht aktuelles Thema, natürlich nicht mit der Tragweite, könnte es aber durchaus auch mal bekommen,
je nachdem wenn es /unverständlich/ so ein Pflanzenvirus und Ernten zerstört.
Dann Teile im Ausland gemacht.
Also nach meiner Doktorarbeit nach Frankreich gegangen, ganz andere Wissenschaftssysteme kennengelernt.
Das war also schon eine Erfahrung.
Also wie zum Beispiel Franzosen über Wissenschaft nachdenken, das sind stellenweise ganz andere Gedankenansätze,
die die dann auch formulieren.
Für mich eine sehr sehr schöne Erfahrung gewesen.
Bin dann nach Australien für ein paar Monate gegangen.
Auch wieder eine ganz andere Herangehensweise kennengelernt.
Und bin dann zurückgekommen, das war so 98, 1998, also noch im letzten Jahrtausend
und bin dann noch mal kurz ans Max-Planck und dann hat mich jemand angerufen und meinte,
er würde jetzt Fraunhofer Direktor werden von einem Fraunhofer-Institut und ob ich da Interesse hätte, das mit aufzubauen.
Und ehrlich gesagt, zu der Zeit kannte ich Fraunhofer nicht.
Also Max-Planck kennt jeder, Max-Planck ist die Krönung und das kennt jeder.
Und ich wollte auch nie weg da.
Also Grundlagenforschung ist ja schön, man kann ja an dem Institut, heute ist das vielleicht auch wieder ein bisschen anders,
zu 100 Prozent Forschung machen halt, man hat keine Lehre, man muss das und das und das nicht machen.
Ich fand aber das auch spannend, bei Fraunhofer zu sein und bin dann ins Sauerland mehr oder weniger gekommen.
Also ich bin gebürtiger Kölner, bin also in Köln groß geworden, ich liebe halt Großstädte halt auch
und bin dann so, dann wurde mir gesagt, ja das Institut, was du jetzt erst mal mit aufbauen musst,
das ist im Sauerland, in Schmallenberg.
Also wirklich, das ist so, was der Engländer sagt, out in the Boonies, also da ist wirklich gar nichts so richtig,
was Kultur angeht, da leben natürlich Menschen, das ist alles nicht schlimm.
Aber für einen Großstädter war das schon eine andere Geschichte.
Ja.
Da habe ich dann vier Jahre gearbeitet und dann habe ich mir gesagt, das willst du nicht so weiter machen halt.
Mir fehlte eben halt so der Bezug auch wieder zur Grundlagenforschung, der Bezug eben halt auch zu Ausbildung.
Und hatte mich dann im Jahre 2004, da wurde eine Professur hier in Münster ausgeschrieben, habe mich darauf beworben
und die haben mich dann genommen und so bin ich dann heute hier.
Super.
Ja, und hier gibt es auf jeden Fall genug zu tun.
Was ist denn jetzt hier so der Fokus an diesem Institut?
Biologie und Biotechnologie der Pflanzen, okay gut, das klingt in gewissen Maßen eingeschränkt, aber nicht sonderlich.
Das ist richtig, ja.
Also wir haben acht Lehrstühle hier an dem Institut.
Und das ist wirklich ein breiter Blumenstrauß an verschiedensten Disziplinen.
Also es gibt einen, der forscht mit Algen, andere forschen bei der Wurzelentwicklung.
Calcium, der Einfluss von Calcium auf Stoffwechselwege.
Was wir machen, also was mein Lehrstuhl hier tut, ist, wir versuchen grundlegende Dinge im Stoffwechsellauf zu erklären.
Also gerade in Richtung Biopolymere.
Das sind so unsere…
Ja, unser Fokus unserer Wissenschaft liegt wirklich auf Biopolymeren, das ist dann Naturkautschuk,
das ist durchaus Stärken in der Kartoffel.
Und versuchen, den dahinterliegende Produktionsweg in der Pflanze aufzuklären.
Und über das Wissen dann eben halt Pflanzen zu optimieren.
Und das ist vielleicht das Spannende hier an der WWU, wir haben hier die Möglichkeit, wir mache nicht nur reine Grundlagenforschung,
sondern wir machen auch den Transfer von dem, was wir denken, was irgendwo eine Marktrelevanz haben könnte,
das betreiben wir hier auch.
Da ist das Interesse doch gestiegen in letzter Zeit oder?
Das ist gestiegen halt, ja, definitiv halt.
Also wir sehen schon also die Notwendigkeit.
Also es wird auch von den Studierenden immer mehr so artikuliert, dass man das, was man im Labor macht,
auch irgendwo in einer Form einen gesellschaftlichen Nutzen haben sollte.
Ich glaube, man sollte aufpassen, man sollte jetzt nicht sagen, jeder muss jetzt unbedingt irgendwas aus seiner Grundlage entwickeln,
aber das, wo man die Möglichkeit sieht, das sollte man zumindest open geben.
Also ich sage immer, diese Open Innovation, dass man sagt, ich will ja nur Grundlage machen,
aber hier nimm es und mach es weiter oder eben halt, wenn man die Möglichkeiten hat und die Chancen sieht,
dann eben halt mit Partnern von mir aus dann eben das auch weiter zu entwickeln.
Da scheint es ja auch noch eine Menge Potenzial zu geben.
Ich meine, wenn man sich jetzt anschaut, wir erleben ja jetzt im Prinzip so eine langsame Abkehr der ölbasierten Wirtschaft
oder ölbasierten Industrieproduktion.
Dieses Ganze, ach lass uns einfach Öl nehmen Plastik zack bumm, Polyethylen, was nicht alles.
Erzeugt so viel Belastung für die Natur, Belastung auch für die Menschen dann natürlich im zweiten und dritten Schritt,
so dass es ja einen großen Bedarf gibt so, können wir Verpackungsmaterial in irgendeiner Form durch etwas ersetzen,
was aus der Natur kommt, was im Idealfall halt gut abbaubar ist etc.
bis hin zur Bionik, jetzt ist das natürlich hier kein Thema,
aber ich habe so den Eindruck, der Kopf öffnet sich langsam wieder so für die Natur
und wird jetzt nicht nur so als das angesehen, wo man gerne Urlaub macht,
sondern dass das eben auch insbesondere dann auch für die Industrie eine relevante Quelle sein kann.
Da sprechen Sie was interessantes an, und zwar als ich angefangen hatte, gerade mit Pflanzen zu arbeiten,
das waren die Zeiten, wo so diese ersten transgenen Pflanzen entwickelt wurden.
Und dann gab es immer so diese beiden Richtungen, wo man gesagt hat,
es gibt diese natürliche Richtung, das sind diese Pflanzen, die eben halt da sind, aufs Feld gehen, gezüchtet werden.
Es gab diese neue Linie, die gesagt hat, über das Verständnis der Gene,
also dass ich eben bei einer Pflanze dann mal das Genom sequenziert habe,
dann sehe eben halt, gibt es relevante Gene, dann irgendwo diesen Pfad zusammenzubringen.
Und das sah eine Zeit lang so aus, dass das überhaupt nicht funktionieren kann
und das sind so Parallelwege gewesen.
Es gibt jetzt mittlerweile durchaus Bestreben, halt auch vielleicht durch diese neuen Technologien wie Genom-Editierung,
wo man auf beiden Seiten auch sieht, man kann das ein bisschen annähern halt.
Es wird jetzt noch nicht so sein, dass wir hier in den nächsten fünf Jahren irgendwie darüber reden werden,
transgene Pflanzen oder genom-editierte Pflanzen aufs Feld zu bringen, aber das Verständnis wird besser.
Was genau bezeichnet transgene Pflanzen?
Transgen wäre jetzt, wenn ich da wirklich ein Fremdgen drin habe halt.
Mal so ein einfaches Beispiel, ich könnte ja jetzt hingehen, ich habe eine Kartoffel
und die Kartoffel hat ein Problem mit einem Pathogen, mit einem Virus als Beispiel.
Jetzt gibt es viele Wildkartoffeln und die sind zum Beispiel resistent gegen dieses Virus.
Jetzt kann ich die ja klassisch kreuzen.
Das Problem ist nur bei der klassischen Kreuzung, ich kreuze ja nicht nur die Resistenz rein,…
...sondern alles.
… sondern alles.
Das heißt also, die Performance der Elitepflanze, die ich ja mal irgendwann am Ende des Tages gezüchtet habe, bricht wieder zusammen.
Jetzt kann ich aber das Gen rausnehmen und durch einen gentechnischen Eingriff könnte ich das eben halt in die Hochleistungslinie bringen,
dann habe ich also nach wie vor meine Hochleistungslinie plus diese Resistenz.
Das kann man auch als cis-Genetik bezeichnen, weil das eben von der Kartoffel in die Kartoffel geht,
was ich auch immer durch klassische Kreuzung machen könnte.
Bei Transgenität wäre es so, ich nehme jetzt ein menschliches Gen und bringe das in die Kartoffel rein.
Also das was nie zusammen kommen könnte.
Das wäre jetzt ein Beispiel eine transgene Pflanze halt.
Okay, verstehe.
Okay, also man merkt, die Genscherentechnik hat auf jeden Fall auch eine ganze Menge ermöglicht da in der letzten Zeit.
Man sieht ja auch die Vorteile halt.
Also ich meine, man darf ja nicht so denken, dass es draußen auf dem Feld keine Probleme gibt.
Ob das Ökolandbau ist, ob es der konventionelle Landbau ist, da sind ja genug Probleme da.
Und es muss immer wieder gezüchtet werden halt.
Also jetzt nehmen wir den Klimawandel, auf einmal werden die Gebiete trockener,
diese Pflanzen sind dann nicht adaptiert, also da muss ich wieder anfangen trockentolerantere Pflanzen dann zu selektionieren oder zu züchten
und so ein Zuchtprozess der dauert halt, das ist Zeit.
Also die letzte durchgezüchtete Pflanze Zuckerrübe 200 Jahre, unter Napoleon gefördert
und gesagt, ihr müsst das jetzt mal als europäische Kulturpflanze dann etablieren
und das hat 200 Jahre gedauert.
Das kann man ja heute nicht mehr, das kann man ja keinem Menschen mehr verkaufen.
Wenn Sie sagen, ich brauche 200 Jahre und dann sprechen wir uns wieder.
Also heute muss das schneller gehen halt und da helfen natürlich so Technologien wie Genom-Editierung immens.
So Naturverbundenheit und Stichwort wie Gentechnik sind ja so in den letzten Jahrzehnten,
gerade in Deutschland, sagen wir mal, nicht unbedingt gemeinsam gefeiert worden.
Da gab es ja sehr viel Widerstand.
Ändert sich das, dieser Blickwinkel, wird das differenzierter?
Weil ich habe oft den Eindruck, dass da auch viele Missverständnisse im Raum sind.
Also ich würde mal sagen, wenn man das jetzt mal so einteilt zwischen der klassischen Gentechnik,
wenn man das mal so bezeichnen darf oder Gentechnik 1.0 oder der ersten Generation und der neuen Gentechnik,
also für die Genom-Editierung da ist deutlich mehr Verständnis da, weil auch die Veränderung,
die man nachher durchführt, nicht so dramatisch ist wie jetzt bei der ersten Generation.
Also man macht da ja nicht dieses menschliche Gen jetzt in die Pflanze rein.
Hat man bei der ersten Generation jetzt auch nicht gemacht, weil man das auf dem Feld unbedingt haben wollte,
sondern da gab es so Ansätze, dass man Pharmaka oder Antikörper in Pflanzen produziert hat,
weil das natürlich die Pflanze per se eine billiges Produktionssystem ist.
Aber mit der neuen Methode führe ich keine fremden Gene da rein, sondern ich modifiziere die Genome.
Und da kommen die Leute schon eher zusammen, ja, weil das kann ich auch machen mit Radioaktivität oder Chemie,
das wird ja gemacht in der klassischen Mutationszüchtung, da nimmt man eben ziemlich heftige Chemie
oder Radioaktivität und dann kann ich auch Mutationen im Genom induzieren,
das ist aber dann nicht spezifisch, sondern das ist einfach wahllos.
Ich habe nachher eine Pflanze, wir haben das auch mal gemacht, die hat nicht nur eine Mutation drin,
die man haben möchte, sondern zig tausend.
Das heißt, danach muss ich wieder züchten, züchten, züchten, um diese ganzen Mutationen,
die unerwünscht sind, rauszubringen.
Jetzt mit einem Verfahrend wie CRIPR als Genom-Editierungsschere da kann ich wirklich gezielt punktgenau eine einzige Mutation setzen.
Das ist mittlerweile so optimiert, also wir haben Pflanzen hier auch mit CRISPR gemacht,
die tragen nachher wirklich die eine einzige Mutation, die unterscheiden sich also von der Ausgangspflanze nur durch diese eine Mutation.
Also eigentlich perfekt.
Nachhaltig, das ist ein Protein, das ist ein bisschen RNA was man dafür braucht,
das andere ist Radioaktivität und Chemie, die nicht ganz gesund ist halt.
Oder halt Jahrhunderte lange Zuchterfolge mit Langzeitbeobachtung und so weiter.
Ganz genau.
Ich finde es immer wieder bemerkenswert, ich denke, wir nehmen ja vieles so als gegeben an,
aber wenn man sich mal anschaut, wie sah Mais vor 500 Jahren aus.
Das ähnelt ja sozusagen dem Produkt, was wir heute aus dem Supermarkt kennen, einfach gar nicht.
Das sind so dürre kleine Pflänzchen mit kleinen Körnerchen, da leuchtet nichts gelb etc.
und es ist nicht so saftig und in gewisser Hinsicht halt auch nicht so nahrhaft.
Und das sind ja eben schon die Erfolge der landwirtschaftlichen Zuchtmethoden.
Und jetzt machen wir eben sehr viel mehr Fortschritte darüber, dass man im Prinzip ja,
ich würde es ja mal so eine gesteuerte Evolution nennen.
Ja, das ist richtig, das würde ich auch so sehen halt, wir haben viel gelernt,
welche Gene gute Eigenschaften tragen, welche Gene schlechte Eigenschaften tragen
und dadurch, dass wir jetzt gezielt modulieren können.
Und da gibt es immer so ein sehr schönes Beispiel, also die Kartoffel macht ja Stärke, das kennt man ja,
Kartoffelstärke ist sicherlich so was, was man im Haushalt auch öfter mal benutzt.
Und die Wildstärke besteht im Prinzip aus zwei Polymeren, das ist einmal Amylopektin und Amylose.
Und ohne die Industrie würde man nur das eine haben, also man würde einmal nur Amylopektin oder Amylose haben.
Das kann ich nachher natürlich machen, ich kann die Wildtypstärke rausnehmen und trennen,
aber das kostet viel Energie und viel Chemie.
Jetzt kann ich aber die Kartoffel so modifizieren, dass sie nur noch reine Amylopektin Stärke macht auf dem Feld.
Das heißt nachher, derjenige, der das extrahiert, braucht nicht mehr viel Energie und viel Chemie da rein zu tun,
sondern er kriegt direkt vom Feld, also von der Natur, die entsprechende Stärke.
Finde ich, das ist ein sehr guter Ansatz halt.
Wenn ich es jetzt wieder zurückspiele auf eine Züchtung, dann muss ich erst mal eine Mutation in der Natur finden,
wo das Gen mutiert ist und dann muss ich 15-20 Jahre züchten, bis ich das Gen drin habe aus der Wildpflanze
und mit Genom-Editierung kann ich so was durchaus in einem Jahr hinbekommen.
Jetzt ist ja der Anlass unseres Gespräches diese Normierung, diese Nominierung ist ausgebrochen worden für eine Kooperation,
eine Team-Kooperation, Sie sind ja sozusagen einer von dreien, die dort genannt sind.
Dann wiederum natürlich auch respektive für ein größeres Team, nehme ich an.
Dr. Kalla Reka(?) von Continental, der Reifenfirma, und Christian Schulze Gronover, vom…
… Fraunhofer Institut.
… vom Fraunhofer Institut.
Wie sind Sie da zusammengekommen, was war da der Anlass, wie ergibt sich so eine Kooperation überhaupt?
Also das Fraunhofer Institut und das universitäre Institut, das ist relativ einfach, weil das ist eine Personalunion sozusagen.
Weil es ja hier sozusagen auch noch eine Fraunhofer Außenstelle hier auch noch gibt, wo Sie der Leiter sind.
Als ich damals den Ruf bekommen habe, habe ich dann eben halt diese Fraunhofer Außenstelle mitgenommen hier.
Okay.
Und Herr Schulze Gronover ist dann eben Leiter des Feldes für Biopolymere.
Und er hat also viel diese Wissenschaftlichkeit gemacht halt, also welche Gene,
wie ich eben schon mal gesagt habe, sind verantwortlich für die Produktion eben von Naturkautschuk.
Und wir haben de facto angefangen, also ich habe angefangen im Jahre 1999 mit der Forschung.
Und das hat aber eine ganz andere Bewandtnis gehabt halt, es hat uns damals wirklich interessiert,
was ist diese weiße Milch, was ist da drin, was kann man damit machen.
Aus dem normalen Kautschukbaum?
Nein, aus unserem Löwenzahn, der hier wächst.
Ah okay.
Weil wir gedacht habe, also da war nicht viel bekannt in der Grundlage und wir hatten uns überlegt,
also diese Milch kann man ja relativ einfach isolieren.
Moment, vielleicht erst mal Kautschuk, ich meine, man assoziiert das halt einfach mit dem sogenannten Gummibaum,
weil da eben dieser Saft auch rauskommt und all das Gummi, was wir so kennen, das Naturgummi, kommt von diesem Baum.
Da wird die Rinde angeritzt und das tropft dann halt so langsam aus diesem Baum heraus,
wird aufwändig gesammelt und dann weiter verarbeitet.
Aber das ist quasi nicht die einzige Pflanze, die so einen Stoff produziert.
Nein, also es gibt bei den Pflanzen ungefähr 125000 Arten, die eben halt auch diese weiße Milch produzieren.
Es gibt aber nur drei, die die Milch so produzieren oder die Inhaltsstoffe in der Milch so produzieren,
dass sie industriell verwertbar sind, das ist einmal der Kautschukbaum, der jetzt eben halt als Hauptquelle für Naturkautschuk dient,
dann ist es der russische Löwenzahn oder Taraxacum kok-saghyz, das ist russisch oder kasachisch
und das heißt so ungefähr wie grüner Kaugummi, weil die kauen auch wirklich da drauf,
ich habe es einmal gemacht, das schmeckt also wirklich grottig, also keinem zu empfehlen.
Und dann gibt es die Guayule, das ist so ein, ja der lebt so in semiariden Gebieten kommt die vor die Pflanze,
ist auch eine zweijährige Pflanze.
Halbtrockene Gebiete.
Halbtrockene Gebiete, genau und da kann man auch diesen Kautschuk draus extrahieren.
Das machen die Amerikaner sehr viel mit dieser Guayule.
Was ist das für eine Pflanze, auch eine Blume oder?
Ja, das ist auch so ein Korbblüter wie der Löwenzahn halt, ist ein bisschen strauchiger, also größer, deutlich größer
und von der Blüte her weiß ich gar nicht, ich glaube, es hat auch gelbe Blüten, aber da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher.
Okay, aber unser Löwenzahn hier aus unseren Breiten, den man hier im Garten vorfindet, der hat keinen Kautschuk?
Der hat ein bisschen nur drin, der ist also nicht geeignet halt.
Wir haben uns das genau angeschaut eben, man findet ganz geringe Mengen an Kautschuk in dieser Milch aus dem Löwenzahn,
aber das lohnt sich nicht, also das rechnet sich nicht.
Man muss so eine gewisse Schwelle überschreiten, damit man auch den Kautschuk extrahieren kann.
Und das ist so unterschwellig bei dem einheimischen Löwenzahn, dass man es nicht verwenden kann.
Deswegen sage ich immer bei meinen Vorträgen, weil ich das immer wieder erfahren habe,
egal ob das nationale oder internationale Vorträge gewesen sind,
wenn wir das vorstellen bekomme ich spätestens eine halbe Stunde später eine Email
oder einen Brief oder was immer noch und dann bieten mir Leute unendlich viele Löwenzähne an halt, die sie dann vorbeibringen.
Das ist alles lieb und nett, aber das bringt nichts, weil das könnten wir nicht verwenden das Material.
Okay, also es ist der sogenannte russische Löwenzahn, der aber eigentlich aus Kasachstan stammt?
Genau.
Vielleicht da kurz zu, wie das dazu gekommen ist.
Der russische Löwenzahn heißt eigentlich deswegen russischer Löwenzahn,
weil Stalin damals gesagt hat, das große Sowjetreich hat alles nur keinen Kautschuk.
Und hat dann seine Botaniker dann eben damit verpflichtet und beauftragt,
sie sollen mal in das ganze Reich gehen und dann mal schauen, ob sie nicht irgendwo eine Alternative finden,
die auch Naturkautschuk produziert, also eine andere Pflanze.
Und die haben das dann gemacht und sind dann irgendwann in dieses Xinjiang Gebirge gegangen
und das ist insofern interessant, weil da hat die Eiszeit aufgehört, also die Gletscher haben da aufgehört.
Großes Gebirge, der Gletscher dagegen gelaufen, das heißt, alles was dahinter liegt, das war dann eben verschont geblieben von der Eiszeit.
Und das ist ein Tal, das nennt sich dann also das Tal in den Xinjiang Gebirgen
und da ist eine unwahrscheinlich hohe pflanzliche Biodiversität drin.
Und da kommt eben halt dieser russische oder kasachische Löwenzahn wächst halt da.
Der macht halt sehr viel Kautschuk in seinen Wurzeln schon mal von der Natur aus.
Und das wusste man, weil die Leute da einfach schon den ganzen Tag drauf rumkauen?
Genau, ja.
Das haben die beobachtet, dass die die Wurzel ausgegraben haben und dann darauf wie so eine Art Kaugummi dann darauf rumgekaut haben halt
und hatten dann auch erste so Analysen gemacht.
Also da gibt es so einen Test, da kann man so eine Wurzel brechen und wenn man das ein bisschen auseinanderzieht,
dann sieht man so weiße Fäden da drin.
Also das ist auch so ein Standard, den wir im Augenblick so ein bisschen nehmen,
also wenn wir eine Pflanze haben, wo wir glauben, da ist sehr viel Kautschuk drin,
dann brechen wir die Wurzeln, das kann man auch wirklich so sehen halt.
Ja und die haben die dann mitgenommen, und zwar nach Sankt Petersburg ins Wawilow-Institut,
das ist so einer der führenden Saatgutbänke in Russland und da haben die die Pflanze erst mal so eingelagert vor allem,
aber auch schon so ein bisschen angefangen zu züchten halt.
Und als es dann in die Kriegsjahre ging und Japan eben Südostasien besetzt gehabt hat,
dann haben natürlich die ganzen Alliierten Mächte keinen Naturkautschuk mehr bekommen
und ohne Kautschuk kann ich keinen Krieg führen, das war damals einfach so.
Wegen der Reifen.
Wegen der Reifen halt.
Und haben dann angefangen intensiv eben, halt einmal auf der amerikanischen Seite diese Guayule zu beforschen
und auf der russischen Seite eben haben sie diesen russischen Löwenzahn beforscht.
Und als dann Südostasien befreit wurde von den Alliierten eben halt, dass Japan dann zurückgingen,
dann bekamen die Achsenmächte keinen Kautschuk mehr.
Das heißt, dann ist in Deutschland angefangen worden, mit dem russischen Löwenzahn zu forschen.
Was die gemacht haben, auf ihrem Russlandfeldzug haben sie einfach die Pflanze mitgebracht.
Also die wussten darum und haben es mitgebracht und haben damals eben in der Kaiser-Wilhelm-Gesellschaft,
also Vorläufer Max-Planck, auch Zuchtprogramme gehabt, um diesen Löwenzahn zu optimieren
und auch Extraktionsprotokolle entwickelt, um da den Kautschuk überhaupt rauszubekommen halt.
Das kann man alles wunderbar nachlesen, da gibt es so eine Dokumentation in Koblenz,
wo diese gesamte Nazi-Dokumentation hinterlegt ist und die habe ich auch hier
und es ist interessant zu lesen, was da so drin steht, also wer da was gemacht hat.
Und eigentlich ist das dann nicht mehr weiter verfolgt worden, nachdem man in Burna(?) dann eben halt diesen Synthesekautschuk entwickelt hat.
Den konnte man natürlich schneller aus erdölbasierten Quellen dann eben herstellen.
Hat auch vernünftige Eigenschaften gehabt, die konnten Reifen draus bauen
und dann hat man diese Naturkautschukproduktion aus dem russischen Löwenzahn zurückgeführt,
weil die auch nicht so sehr erfolgreich waren.
Das lag einfach daran, die haben Wildpflanzen bearbeitet.
Die Wildpflanze ist nicht so wie man sich das vorstellt.
Also ich hole mir die heute irgendwo aus dem Tal und morgen habe ich hektarweise diese Pflanze im Feld stehen.
Kann man später noch mal drauf eingehen, sondern da muss man einiges tun
und das ist sehr arbeits- und vor allem auch zeitintensiv, deswegen hat man gesagt,
nein, wir gehen auf die synthetische Variante.
Warum hat denn diese Pflanze diesen Kautschuk, warum bildet die den aus?
Das ist ein super Frage, halt wir wissen es bis heute nicht.
Die einzige logische Erklärung ist, das muss ein Fraßschutz sein.
Also die Wurzel schützt sich damit, dass irgendwelche Würmer oder Insekten,
was immer da diese Pflanze dann eben attackieren können.
Das kann man auch so ein bisschen sehen, wir machen so paar Experimente halt mit dem russischen Löwenzahn versus dem einheimischen Löwenzahn
und sehen halt eben, dass beide Pflanzen ein komplett anderes Spektrum an herbivoren Insekten haben halt.
Und das ist sicherlich so ein Grund, in diesem Tal muss es irgendwas geben, was diesen Löwenzahn gerne mag
und der Löwenzahn wehrt sich dagegen eben durch die Produktion von Kautschuk.
Weil das muss man sich, wenn man diese Wurzel durchschneidet, dann sieht man wirklich so einen Gummiring da drin,
das heißt also, das, was da dran frisst, das kann vielleicht die Außenrinde abfressen.
Aber dann ist die wie ein Mantel drum herum.
Genau, und dann hat die wirklich so einen Mantel drin.
Es gab auch schon mal die Idee, so eine Art Thermoschutz, weil da wird es brutal kalt.
Also im Winter, das ist so Kontinentalklima, also Temperaturen beschrieben bis zu -30 Grad, im Sommer plus.
Also die Pflanze die hält so was, die ist ja zweijährig, also die kann mehrjährig sogar sein,
die hält ein Temperaturspektrum von 60 Grad aus, war auch eine Idee,
aber wir glauben eher, dass es ein Fraßschutz ist.
Und unser einheimischer Löwenzahn der muss das irgendwann verloren haben.
Sehr wahrscheinlich deswegen, weil dieses Pathogen oder dieser Krankheitserreger hier nicht vorkommen halt.
Und dann macht es keinen Sinn, das noch zu produzieren.
Genau.
Wenn es denn überhaupt, also weiß man denn, dass unser Löwenzahn mehr oder weniger von dem russischen abstammt?
Haben die irgendwie eine gemeinsame Linie?
Ich meine, ähnlich sind sie ja.
Sind ähnlich halt, also der russische sieht ein bisschen vom Habitus ein bisschen anders aus.
Der macht viel mehr Blüten als unserer, das liegt einfach an der Fortpflanzungsbiologie.
Der vermehrt sich sexuell, das macht unserer nicht.
Wir haben die Genome sequenziert von beiden Pflanzen, wir sehen sehr sehr viele Ähnlichkeiten in der DNA.
Aber wir sehen auch deutliche Unterschiede und vor allem in der Kautschukbiosynthese sehen wir Unterschiede halt.
Wir sehen also das was er verloren hat oder vielleicht nie gehabt hat, das kann natürlich auch sein,
dass der russische evolutiv vielleicht jünger ist und das irgendwann mal dazu gewonnen hat.
Aber die sind wahrscheinlich irgendwie aus einem gemeinsamen Stamm irgendwann hervorgegangen,
den es so jetzt in der Form nicht mehr gibt.
Genau.
Was man aber sieht, es gibt Hybride, die also zusammen gekommen sind, also wo der russische mit dem einheimischen dann zusammen gekommen ist,
hat einen ganz komplizierten Namen, nennt sich Brevicorniculatum und da sieht man eben so eine Mittelstellung halt.
Der hat ein bisschen mehr Kautschuk als der offizinale, also der einheimische und ein bisschen weniger als der kok-saghyz.
Was macht denn Kautschuk aus, also was ist denn in diesem Stoff eigentlich so,
dass man ihn auch nicht so ohne weiteres durch irgendetwas ersetzen kann?
Also Naturkautschuk im Vergleich zu diesem synthetischen Pendant, der hat eine viel höhere Kälteflexibilität.
Die Zugfestigkeit ist höher und deswegen braucht man das gerade in so Produkten,
die so eine hohe mechanische Belastung haben, also sprich LKW-Reifen halt,
so ein LKW-Reifen, beladener LKW da kann man sich vorstellen, was da für Lasten drauf sind.
Wenn die jetzt zum Beispiel eine Bordsteinkante haben, die ganze Verdehnung, die es da gibt und so was,
das können Sie mit Naturkautschuk ausgleichen, aber nicht mit synthetischem Kautschuk.
Oder Winterreifen, also im Winter habe ich natürlich bei Minusgraden oder was immer ganz andere Ansprüche an die Performance von so einem Reifen,
deswegen ist auch im Winterreifen der Anteil an Naturkautschuk dann eben höher.
So einen klassischen Sommerreifen, den kann ich auch aus Synthesekautschuk bauen halt.
Aber da, wo Kälte, mechanische Belastung viel ist, da brauche ich Naturkautschuk.
Und alle Versuche, die man bis jetzt gemacht hat, dieses Prinzip zu verstehen, was ist eigentlich Naturkautschuk
und warum kann das der Synthesekautschuk nicht oder kann ich die Eigenschaften übertragen,
sind bis vor einem Jahr immer fehlgeschlagen.
Also wir wissen mittlerweile was die Kompetenten sind, man kann sie auch übertragen.
Man kriegt auch ein neues Material und das ist gerade in der Testung halt.
Ich glaube, wir haben jetzt wenn wir mit unserem Naturkautschuk arbeiten, mit Löwenzahn, verstanden,
was eigentlich die biologischen Komponenten sind in dem Kautschuk, weil von der Chemie ist das das gleiche Synthese und Naturkautschuk,
aber da sind natürlich biologische Faktoren mit drin im Naturkautschuk und die machen eben halt diese besonderen Eigenschaften.
Das heißt, sie enthalten eigentlich dieselben Stoffe, nur sind diese Stoffe anders miteinander verbunden?
Genau, ja.
Okay.
Tja, also es gibt noch viele Rätsel zu klären.
So und jetzt ist natürlich klar, wenn man eigentlich weiß, okay es gibt diese Pflanze,
die hat im Prinzip das was man will und warum ist denn überhaupt die Nachfrage nach einer alternativen Quelle so hoch?
Also was ist das Problem jetzt mit dem Gummibaum?
Also man muss sich einfach mal die Produktion angucken, das ist auch irgendwo wo ich mein biologisches Herz verloren habe drin.
Seit etlichen Jahren betreue ich auch Projekte, die mit der Ölpalme in Verbindung stehen,
wo man eben sieht, ich war sehr oft vor Ort in Südostasien, wo man sieht eben,
was so der Impact von diesen Pflanzen auf diese Ökosysteme dann ist.
Also vor allen in den Monokulturen, die damit verbunden sind.
Ja. Und was man sehen kann, wenn der Bedarf hier in Europa steigt und Europa ist halt so ein Pull.
Nordamerika, Europa und wenn man hier sagt, ich kann mich an diese Zeiten erinnern,
wo es auf einmal hieß, wir brauchen Biodiesel, Biodiesel, Biodiesel, dafür braucht man Öl
und Palmöl ist natürlich das, da kann ich die größten Mengen mit produzieren.
Die haben natürlich sofort reagiert, weil so eine Ölpalme, bis die produktiv wird dauert 20 Jahre,
das heißt also, ich muss schon jetzt anfangen, um in 20 Jahren damit auch Geld zu verdienen,
das haben die dann gemacht mit dem Resultat, dass unwahrscheinlich viele Urwälder zerstört worden sind.
Das gleiche passiert auch mit dem Naturkautschuk halt.
Also wenn jetzt, und das sehen wir ja, es gibt einen Mehrbedarf, der liegt bei ungefähr 500000 Tonnen
in den 20, 30er Jahren und diesen Mehrbedarf mit dem Kautschukbaum zu decken heißt,
ich muss Urwald holzen, und zwar in dem Sinn kann man es genau umrechnen, eine Tonne pro Hektar,
500000 Hektar müssen dann wieder zum Opfer fallen und das ist eben halt das, was man auch sieht.
Und deswegen ist es sehr sehr sinnvoll hinzugehen und da etwas gegenzustellen.
Und wenn ich mit Leuten rede sage ich immer, man darf nicht nur motzen halt.
Es gibt ja viele Leute, die sagen, das können wir so nicht machen, das ist ganz katastrophal
und wie kann das überhaupt sein?
Ich sage den Leuten immer, ihr müsst euch bewusst sein, wir sind ja eigentlich diejenigen,
die das da unten verursachen, die machen ja nicht aus Spaß ihre Urwälder da abzuholzen,
sondern die sehen einen Bedarf auf dem europäischen Markt und der ist extrem,
Soja zum Beispiel in Südamerika auch ein Beispiel, dann holen die sich das Go mehr oder weniger ein,
wie sehen eure Märkte aus und dann passiert das, was wir eben halt im Augenblick überall auf diesem Planeten,
gerade in diesen Tropenregionen sehen.
Und um dem entgegenwirken zu können, müssen wir eine Alternative entwickeln, also wir müssen eine Alternative anbieten.
Sonst durch Reden wird das nichts werden halt.
Sondern wir müssen sagen, wir brauchen in Europa eine Proteinpflanze, die eben Soja ersetzt.
Wir brauchen eine Naturkautschukpflanze, die auch den Kautschukbaum teilweise ersetzen kann
und wir brauchen Ölpflanzen.
Da sind wir gut unterwegs, wir haben Raps und Leinen und alles mögliche, da gibt es viele Pflanzen,
da sind wir sicher am besten unterwegs.
Aber bei Naturkautschuk gab es gar nichts.
Und das war jetzt auch so die Intension zu sagen,…
Gibt es was bei Soja?
Man baut mittlerweile im Süden Soja an, das sind so die ersten Versuche.
Also so ein bisschen so diese /unverständlich/ daran zu machen,
aber was man auch hat sind eben halt diese ganzen Lupinen zum Beispiel,
da hat es auch mal einen Zukunftspreis für gegeben, das ist eine Pflanze, die Protein macht.
Es gibt Erbsen, Bohnen, diese Dinge kommen wieder rein, sind von der Kulturführung schwierig,
aber wird mit Sicherheit auch wieder mehr zu sehen sein auf den Feldern halt.
Weil wenn wir dem entgegenwirken wollen, gerade in Südamerika und da ist es wirklich dramatisch,
wenn man sich das anschaut, müssen wir so was dann eben auf den Markt bringen.
Oder vielleicht einfach immer noch so als Tipp, weniger Fleisch essen, dann wäre das Problem eh weg.
Oder weniger Auto fahren.
Und weniger Reifen kaufen.
Aber das ist ja das Problem mit unserer Konsumgesellschaft.
Klar, auch da kann man steuern, aber auch das ist natürlich ein langsamer Prozess
und letzten Endes muss man irgendwie immer alles gleichzeitig probieren, also sonst kommt man ja irgendwie nirgendwo hin.
Mit anderen Worten, wir haben ein Problem mit der Gummiproduktion, die Gumminachfrage ist nach wie vor groß in der Industrie,
vor allem für Reifen, aber nicht nur, aber ich denke, Reifen sind so eigentlich der Großteil oder?
70 Prozent.
70 Prozent, okay, also signifikant.
Es gibt in zunehmendem Maße auch so ein Käuferbewusstsein für solche Sachen,
dass, wenn man sagt, okay guck mal, das Produkt ist irgendwie jetzt mal anders erzeugt,
dann kann man damit auch eine gewisse Aufmerksamkeit schaffen, das reicht alleine sicherlich noch nicht
und es wäre halt gut, eine Alternative zu haben.
So jetzt hat man einfach diesen russischen Löwenzahn und jetzt sind wir, glaube ich, so an dem Punkt,
wo dieses Team dann auch in irgendeiner Form ein bisschen enger zusammengearbeitet hat.
Ich vermute mal, Continental hat gesagt, so Leute wie sieht es denn jetzt eigentlich aus
hier mit dem anderen Kautschuk, kann man den jetzt mal irgendwie benutzen?
Was muss denn jetzt hier geschehen?
Also wir hatten de facto mit dem russischen Löwenzahn kurze Zeit vorher angefangen,
weil wir hatten diese gesamten Löwenzähne, die man so kriegen kann,
also wir hatten die so vergleichend studiert und hatten diese Ergebnisse mal auf einem Kongress in Aachen vorgestellt,
und da waren Vertreter von Continental im Publikum.
Wann war das?
Das war 2008/09 muss das gewesen sein.
Und dann sind wir zusammen gekommen und haben gesagt, naja das ist eine spannende Geschichte
und da haben wir dann auch unsere Arbeiten ein bisschen intensiviert in Richtung Kautschukbiosynthese,
also die Herstellung von Kautschuk im russischen Löwenzahn.
Und das war eine interessante Zeit, weil da sind wir auch dann hingegangen und haben gesagt,
wir können das nicht aus Bordmitteln machen.
Also jeder weiß vielleicht, Universitäten da ist das Geld jetzt nicht so stark vertreten halt,
dass man da einfach mal so ein bisschen so.
Wächst noch nicht auf dem Feld.
Nein, wächst nicht auf dem Feld halt.
Und sind dann zur öffentlichen Fördereinrichtung gegangen.
Also das war eine Zeit, wo ich auch gesagt habe, schade eigentlich, dass man mit so einer Idee nicht auf Anklang stoßen kann.
Das ist so, wir wurden wirklich regelrecht ausgelacht.
Von wem jetzt?
Von Förderern halt, jetzt ohne die Fördereinrichtung zu benennen.
Ja, aber so private oder staatliche?
Staatliche, die gesagt haben, was ist das denn für eine spinnerte Idee halt, also Löwenzahn, so ein Blödsinn.
Oder Meetings anberaumt wurden, wo wir das vorstellen sollten und dann sind die Leute einfach nicht gekommen.
Und es war halt ein schöner Moment, ich hatte vor fünf Jahren Glück gehabt, noch mal einen Vortrag halten zu dürfen,
wo sie alle im Publikum, im Auditorium standen und…
Alle, die nein gesagt haben.
Und dann doch irgendwie gesagt haben, oh das hätten sie sich nie vorgestellt halt
und wäre toll, dass es jetzt so funktioniert hat.
Ist im Nachgang auch besser geworden halt.
Als man mit Continental zusammen gekommen ist, da wurde auch gesagt, naja also wenn so ein großer Reifenproduzent da drin ist,
dann ist das so ein bisschen so ein Signal, da scheint mehr dran zu sein als so eine spinnerte Idee
von ein paar Wissenschaftlern aus irgendeinem Institut in Deutschland oder auf dieser Welt.
Und dann war der Vorteil eben halt, dass wir gesagt haben von Anfang an, wir gehen auf eine ganze Wertschöpfungskette.
Wir hätten ja anfangen können mit der Züchtung und sagen, wir züchten einfach mal
und wenn wir soweit denken, das ist alles super, dann gehen wir zu einer Firma und sagen,
hier wir haben schöne neue Naturkautschukquelle, testet mal.
Dann passiert eben das, was oftmals passiert, dann macht man den Test und dann wird hinten festgestellt, das stimmt alles nicht mehr.
Deswegen war uns von Anfang an wichtig, die Rückmeldung aus dem Produkt zu haben.
Wir haben also immer bei jedem Züchtungsschritt immer geschaut, hier habt ihr ein bisschen was,
schaut euch an, ist die Performance noch da.
Weil wenn man es nicht so machen würde, könnte es am Ende des Tages passieren,
dass man eine super gezüchtete Löwenzahnpflanze hat, die aber dann eigentlich nur noch Kaninchenfutter ist halt,
weil der wertgebende Stoff der ist dann nicht mehr drin.
Und dieser Prozess eben dieser Überführung, das ist oftmals auch so was, wo ein bisschen gesagt wird,
naja ist eine Pflanze halt.
Ich amüsiere mich immer köstlich darüber, das gibt es ja alle Jahre wieder, da kommt so ein Bericht,
da ist irgendein Wissenschaftler in irgendeinen Urwald auf diesem Planeten gegangen
und dann holt er eine Pflanze raus und die rettet die ganze Welt.
Heureka.
Ja, die braucht keinen Dünger, die braucht kein Wasser, die braucht noch nicht mal Boden oder irgendwas, die wächst eigentlich so
und das ist wirklich Blödsinn.
das sind Pflanzen, das sind Wildpflanzen, wenn man in diesem kasachischen Tal ist, dann sieht die ja auch sehr schön aus,
aber wenn ich die da rausnehme, Samen davon mache und das haben wir auch getan wirklich so
und sind aufs Feld gegangen, das ist eine Katastrophe halt, da wächst eine super, die andere wächst gar nicht,
die andere wächst ein bisschen, die andere fällt vor Krankheit um.
Und das war der Moment, wo wir gesagt haben, das ist klar, wir müssen jetzt hier züchten halt.
Sein lassen oder züchten.
Da haben wir gesagt, nein wir wollen die Pflanze wirklich entwickeln.
Und dann eben über Selektion zusammen mit einem Pflanzenzüchter, das haben wir gar nicht mehr gemacht,
sondern wir haben einen Pflanzenzüchter, der das dann eben aktiv betreibt
und dann die Eliten immer wieder gekreuzt halt.
Und das ist der Weg eben, deswegen heißt es auch Züchtung, der Pflanze was beizubringen, was wir jetzt gerne von ihr hätten.
Und das dauert halt seine Zeit.
Und wir haben jetzt eben als Beispiel mal, das ist immer das Merkmal, wo wir am weitesten mit sind,
vom Kautschukgehalt von rund 2-3 Prozent sind wir jetzt auf 15-20 Prozent hochgekommen in den zehn Jahren.
Zwei Prozent im Verhältnis zu was?
Nur die Wurzeln?
Ja, man nimmt die Wurzel, trocknet die, und zwei Prozent der Trockenwurzelmasse oder des Trockengewichts ist dann eben Kautschuk.
Jetzt im ursprünglichen Zustand?
Im ursprünglichen genau.
Und durch die Züchtung konnte das dann gesteigert werden?
Auf 15-20 Prozent, ja.
15-20 Prozent, ah also ein Fünftel der Wurzel im Maximalfall ist einfach unmittelbar nutzbares Kautschuk.
Und das ist auch von der Art her genauso wie das Kautschuk, was aus dem Gummibaum kommt?
Ja, genau, also das ist ja das Schöne gewesen, also die ersten Studien haben ganz klar belegt,
dass es auf jeden Fall äquivalent ist, die Eigenschaften, also die konnten den Rohstoff so nehmen wie er ist.
Aber bei der Continental, das war auch sehr herausfordernd, die konnten das jetzt nicht nehmen
und einfach in die Mischer reinschmeißen, die sie da standardmäßig laufen lassen für Synthese
oder Kautschuk aus dem Kautschukbaum, sondern da mussten auch die Prozesse alle adaptiert werden halt,
weil das Polymer an sich oder dieser Rohstoff, der da rauskommt, das ist nicht so diese weiße Milch, die man kennt,
wo man den Kautschuk rausholt, sondern das ist mehr so ein bräunlicher Klumpen,
sieht aus wie so ein Schwamm, kann man sagen halt, so ein Naturschwamm.
Und zu diesem Naturkautschuk hat man eben noch andere Komponenten drin,
das liegt einfach an der Extraktion, so wie wir das machen.
Und das führt dazu, dass das ein bisschen klebriger ist das Material.
Das heißt, man konnte also da auch, musste man Prozesse komplett neu denken, um das Material zu verwenden.
Also zumindest vorgeschaltete Prozesse, um überhaupt erst mal denselben Ausgangsstoff zu haben,
ab dem man dann aber auch wirklich dieselben Maschinen und selben Prozesse verwenden konnte?
Genau. Man muss ich überlegen halt, also das hatten Sie eben schon mal angedeutet,
also in Südostasien ist es so, wenn die ihre Bäume, das heißt Tapping, also die gehen da hin
und machen diesen Rindenschnitt, da kennt man diese Kokosschalen, die da drunter hängen,
da tropft diese Milch rein, dann tun die Säure da rein und dann fällt dieser Kautschuk aus aus dieser Milch,
dann hat man eben diesen Feststoff, den man braucht und das wird dann so verschifft.
Das ist dann hochsauber.
Bei uns ist es so, wir nehmen die Wurzel, da ist natürlich ein bisschen Erde immer noch dran gehaftet,
da sind natürlich auch tausende andere Substanzen in der Wurzel drin und die zermahlen wir.
Das ist ein rein wässriger Prozess, das heißt, es ist jetzt nicht irgendwie, dass da irgendwelche organischen Lösungsmittel reinkommen,
die jetzt eben schädlich sind, sondern das ist rein wasserbasiert.
Aber durch diese Extraktion mit dem Wasser kommen natürlich auch andere Substanzen in dieses Polymer rein
und das muss man nachher in diesen Prozess integrieren.
Das scheint aber nicht nachteilig zu sein das zu tun.
Weil die Reifenperformance, die man sieht, ist sehr gut und bei dem Fahrradreifen,
der jetzt gebaut worden ist, da kriegt man auch Rückmeldungen von vielen vielen Nutzern,
die sagen halt, dass die so ein gutes Gefühl darauf haben, weil dieser Grip oder diese Hafteigenschaften des Reifens wohl deutlich besser sind
als das was man vorher hatte.
Kommen wir gleich noch mal zu den Reifen selber, aber mich würde noch mal interessieren,
was jetzt eigentlich konkret im Rahmen dieser Züchtung verändert wurde.
Wir hatten es ja eingangs schon gesagt, Züchtung ist jetzt nicht nur radioaktiv bestrahlen
und dann mal gucken was dabei rauskommt und dann testet man und züchtet mit dem weiter,
was irgendwie am nächsten rankommt, sondern man muss ja schon erst mal auch ein genetisches Verständnis haben,
welches Gen trägt jetzt eigentlich welche Funktion?
Genau.
Woher weiß man das, wie kriegt man das raus?
Vielleicht können wir das auch wieder an der Kautschukbiosynthese festmachen.
Klar gerne.
Wir sind hingegangen und haben also uns diese Milch angeguckt und haben geschaut, was ist denn da an Protein drin?
Da gibt es heute hochmoderne Hochdurchsatzverfahren, das sind diese sogenannten Omex-Technologien(?),
Proteomex(?), Transkriptomex(?), das sind also, wo man mit vielen vielen Daten eben halt Dinge einengen kann
und am Ende des Tages genau da rauskommt auf diese Gene, die einen interessieren.
Und das haben wir ganz einfach gemacht, wir haben also diesen einheimischen Löwenzahn genommen,
der ja kein Kautschuk macht oder wenig und wir haben den russischen genommen, der jetzt viel macht.
Und erst mal verglichen, was haben die gemeinsam und was kann es sozusagen nicht sein.
Was haben sie gemeinsam.
Okay, wieviel bleibt dann noch übrig?
Am Ende sind wir so, das ist noch eine Menge halt, aber sie haben dann immer so um die 150 Gene gehabt eben halt, die da so nahe kamen halt.
Und dann schaut man sich an, werden die noch unterschiedlich gebildet,
also wieviel wird von dem Protein wirklich in den Pflanzen gebildet und dann kommt man wieder ein Stück runter.
Und weil wir das so gemacht haben über die Zeit, haben wir dann nachher so zehn Kandidaten gefunden,
wo wir von glaubten, das müssen Schlüsselkandidaten sein, wirklich die dafür verantwortlich sind.
Was war das so für ein Zeitraum so gefühlt, bis man da an diesem Punkt war?
Ja, das war auch so sechs Jahre, sechs, sieben Jahre, viele Doktorarbeiten dahinter,
also da sitzen Menschen dahinter.
Also wirklich ein Großteil dieser Zeit, wir reden ja jetzt von einem Zeitraum von ungefähr zwölf Jahren,
wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe, also die Hälfte ist sozusagen erst mal nur einengen?
Genau. Und dann eben die Funktionalität auch zu überprüfen, also diesen finalen Beweis.
Da sind wir jetzt wieder bei der Gentechnik.
Also das machen wir in unseren Laboren.
Wir modifizieren dann zum Beispiel eine Pflanze, die viel Kautschuk macht, da schalten wir das Gen aus, so.
Und dann schauen wir uns nachher an, macht die noch Kautschuk?
Und wenn sie keinen mehr macht, dann weiß man, das muss auf jeden Fall ein Faktor sein.
Und dann haben wir über diese letzten verbliebenen haben wir dann halt eben noch weiter eingeengt
und haben dann eben so fünf, sechs Kandidaten, die wirklich ganz wertvoll sind.
Und die finden wir dann auch nicht mehr in dem Offizinale(?) und anderen Löwenzähnen halt.
Und das sind dann eben halt die Dinge, man könnte sagen, ihr habt doch diese schönen Pflanzen,
die ihr schon genetisch verändert habt, die sind doch super, die können doch auf das Feld,
aber dann kommen wir jetzt wieder in diese öffentliche Diskussion, das geht nicht.
Und deswegen haben wir die jetzt genommen, um damit eben halt, wir wissen ja, welches Gen jetzt drin sein muss in der Pflanze.
Und das kann man sich vorstellen wie bei einem Corona-Test, jetzt bei diesem PCR-Test.
Das ist mittlerweile was jeder kennt, PCR, das ist das Schöne, das macht uns das Leben auch ein bisschen einfacher.
Also wir können jetzt sagen, da steht eine Pflanze, und zwar im Keimling, wenn die gerade aus dem Samen rauskommt,
können wir durch eine PCR nachweisen, okay diese Pflanze trägt das Gen natürlich.
Also das hat mit Gentechnik nichts mehr zu tun, sondern natürlicherweise, und diese nicht.
Somit kann der Züchter eben relativ frühzeitig schon seinen Pflanzenpool, also der fängt mit 30.000 an,
kann sie dann auf 100 eingrenzen und diese 100 tragen auch nur diese Eigenschaft dann.
Das war so der Durchbruch.
Und wir haben natürlich weitaus mehrere Merkmale.
Also der russische Löwenzahn der liegt eigentlich platt wie eine Flunder auf dem Acker.
Der stellt seine Blätter nicht hoch.
Habe ich mir damals auch gedacht, das ist jetzt so, weil ich jetzt auch nicht aus der Agronomie komme halt,
kein Problem, aber wie erntet man so was?
Wenn so was ganz flach auf dem Boden liegt, ist unwahrscheinlich schwierig halt.
Weil man es nicht richtig greifen kann.
Man kann es nicht greifen halt, da kann man sich diese Kirmesautomaten vorstellen,
die so eine Puppe unten aus dem Ding greift, aber das hätte alles nicht funktioniert.
Was wir jetzt gemacht haben oder wo wir dabei sind, wir züchten Pflanzen, die halt die Blätter hochstellen.
Das heißt, dann kann ich mit so einem Möhrenernter, das sind sogenannte Klemmbandroder.
Die packen das oben und ziehen es raus.
Weil man will ja die Wurzel haben, das ist ja das wichtige.
Genau, dann habe ich eine Orientierung drin und kann dann die direkt unter Blattgrün abschneiden,
dann habe ich nur noch die Wurzel.
Wenn ich es so ausgrabe, wie wir es eine Zeit lang gemacht haben halt,
also mit diesem Pflug, der einfach die unten abschneidet und nach oben bringt,
dann habe ich nachher aber in tausend Orientierungen da liegen halt.
Das heißt, dann brauche ich wieder eine Maschine, die erst mal das so hinlegt,
dass nachher so ein Cuttermesser, also so ein Messer, was es abschneidet, auch immer an der richtigen Stelle schneidet.
Also die Zukunft ist auf jeden Fall, dass wir so über Klemmbandrodetechnologie gehen.
Das heißt, in der Züchtung müssen wir da auch reagieren drauf.
Dann gibt es Resistenzen, also es gibt natürlich auch Pathogene, die hier auf dem Feld auf einmal da sind,
die der in der Natur nicht gesehen hat.
Zumindest nicht in Kasachstan.
Keine Chance haben halt, da muss man Resistenzzüchtung machen halt.
Also das ist so doch ein breites Portfolio an Eigenschaften, die wir uns angucken.
Was ist denn das natürliche Klima, in dem diese Pflanze eigentlich in Kasachstan so wächst?
Sind das auch trockene Gebiete oder ist das sehr feucht?
Diese Pflanze hat so die Eigenschaft, also haben viele Latexpflanzen,
also das ist normalerweise jetzt wie hier jetzt.
Also wenn es jetzt Frühjahr ist oder irgendwas, es wird im Sommer ein bisschen heißer,
deswegen was die Pflanze auch im Sommer tut, die hat so eine Dormanz, also die zieht sich so zusammen.
So einen Schlafmodus.
Schlafmodus, sie zieht sich so ein bisschen zurück in den Herbst rein und dann treibt sie noch mal gut aus.
Hier auf den Feldern sieht man eigentlich, dass die unter den klimatischen Bedingungen,
also wenn wir jetzt mal vom Klimawandel absehen und die letzten Jahre, die sehr trocken war,
dann kriegt jede Pflanze ein Problem halt.
Ja.
Also wächst die eigentlich ganz vernünftig.
Ist natürlich immer noch, weil viel Wildmaterial drin ist, ist noch nicht das Ende erreicht.
Also Kautschukgehalt ja, aber Performance auf dem Feld nein, da müssen wir noch einiges tun halt,
also dass die konstant den gleichen Phänotypen, also das Aussehen muss konstanter sein halt,
die ist noch so ein bisschen sieht man manchmal, ist sie so wie man sie sich vorstellt
und dann ist sie aber auch wieder so ein bisschen anders aussehend halt und man will so eine Uniformität haben.
Da züchten wir aber auch gerade dran halt.
Auch da holen wir wieder Gene, wo wir von wissen, dass sie dafür verantwortlich sind und nutzen das.
Das heißt, man ist auch noch lange nicht am Ende dieser Reise angekommen.
Nein.
Es ist nur so, das Primärziel, diesen Kautschuk in brauchbaren Mengen zu haben
und ich weiß gar nicht, von welchen Mengen reden wir jetzt eigentlich bei einer einzelnen Pflanze?
Gut, 20 Prozent der Wurzel, wie groß ist die Wurzel?
Ja, so eine Wurzel die wiegt so 200 Gramm, irgendwas halt, das ist nicht viel was da rauskommt.
Okay.
Aber so rechnen wir auch nicht.
Na gut, aber das sind dann 40 Gramm Kautschuk pro einzelner Löwenzahnpflanze,
klingt jetzt nicht wenig.
Nein, wenig ist es nicht halt, aber wir haben immer wieder diese Sache, wie konkurriert ihr mit einem Baum?
Finde ich eine berechtigte Frage, habe ich mir damals auch Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Weil so ein Kautschukbaum, das ist schon ein mächtiges Ding halt.
Aber auch da darf man nicht vergessen, so ein Baum produziert pro Jahr 1,5 Kilogramm Naturkautschuk pro Jahr.
Das ist nicht viel, ich dachte immer, das wäre viel viel mehr, ich dachte immer, das geht schon in den dreistelligen Kilogrammbereich.
Auf dem Hektar stehen ungefähr 600 Bäume, also reden wir so grob über eine Tonne Naturkautschuk pro Hektar.
Jetzt haben wir natürlich auch mit dem Löwenzahn viel viel mehr Pflanzen auf dem Feld.
Und das, wenn wir jetzt diese 15 Prozent, die da sind in den Pflanzen und eben noch diese Biomasse erhöhen,
wo wir gerade dran arbeiten, ist diese Tonne auch das absolut realistische Ziel.
Also das müssen wir auch erreichen, um eben halt, ist halt so, man muss halt den Preis treffen,
der auch bei dem Naturkautschukbaum eben da ist oder man muss dann eben…
Exzellentere Produkte machen oder so High Quality Products oder irgendwas, aber das ist nicht das Ziel.
Oder mehr.
Also es soll wirklich so eins zu eins Ersatz dann auch sein.
Aber der Vorteil ist ja im Prinzip, dass die Pflanze sehr viel anspruchsloser ist als dieser Kautschukbaum.
Während der Kautschukbaum eben dann nur in besonders heißen Regionen, ich weiß gar nicht was die Anforderungen jetzt sind,
dass der gut gedeihen kann.
Das sind so Tropenwälder, also Südostasien, Malaysia, Thailand, da so die Länder, Indonesien.
Okay, also Hitze ist sozusagen ein Faktor, Luftfeuchtigkeit etc., Bodenbeschaffenheit natürlich auch.
Aber dieser Löwenzahn ist ja, ich meine, Löwenzahn kennt man ja, wächst ja überall, hat man so den Eindruck.
Gilt das auch für den russischen Löwenzahn?
Ja, der ist ein bisschen schwäche auf der Brust, sage ich mal, als der einheimische halt.
Den einheimischen kennt man ja, ist ja egal, wenn man auf dem Bürgersteig irgendwo in der Ecke.
Ist nicht wegzukriegen.
Wächst halt überall.
Und der russische Löwenzahn kann sich nicht gegen den einheimischen durchsetzen.
Also wenn man so ein Feld hat, wo beide wachsen, dann überwächst der einheimische den russischen Löwenzahn.
Das sieht man eindeutig.
Natürlich wenn die jetzt züchterisch optimiert wird und die Pflanze natürlich auch immer mehr an die Bodenqualitäten hier angepasst ist,
wird die sicherlich auch mal stärker werden halt.
Aber auch da, also man wird um eine Düngung nicht rumkommen halt.
Man wird auch um Pflanzenschutz nicht rumkommen.
Das was ich eben sagte halt, in der Wildnis überhaupt kein Problem halt, aber da auf dem Feld in einer Monokultur muss man da auch schon was tun.
Aber im Prinzip könnte man sich ja jetzt auch noch mal bei dem einheimischen Löwenzahn genetisch bedienen oder?
Das ist was wir auch tun, wir versuchen so Hybride zu machen, also wir kreuzen den russischen mit dem einheimischen
und versuchen halt diese kautschuktragenden Anteile, also diese Gene, die Kautschuk produzieren,
auf den einheimischen zu übertragen.
Sor um.
Ja, das ist klassische Züchtung, man könnte jetzt wieder dieses …
Man könnte ja auch sagen, man kann auch die Anspruchslosigkeit auf den russischen übertragen.
Das kann man auch machen, geht ja beide Wege halt.
Also was aus Hybrid rauskommt, normalerweise diese Hybride die outperformen, nennt man das,
also die werden besser als die beiden Eltern, die da drin sind.
Das machen wir gerade auch halt, ist auch wieder ein längerer Prozess.
Ist auch nichts was man von heute auf morgen machen kann.
Einfacher wäre es natürlich jetzt wieder, ich nehme mir die Gene raus und bringe die rüber.
Haben wir ja schon diskutiert, dass das nicht geht.
Und aber von seiner Anspruchslosigkeit, also was wir schon sehen ist halt, die brauchen jetzt nicht diese Hochertragsböden.
Wir gehen auf so Sekundärertragsflächen halt, das heißt das sind Flächen, die eigentlich nicht geeignet sind für die Nahrungsproduktion.
Also auch wegzukommen von dieser Tank-Teller-Diskussion.
Wird oftmals gesagt, naja nachher haben wir nichts mehr zu essen und Naturkautschuk für die Reifen.
Nein, das wird es nicht sein.
Was für Flächen wären das dann, die quasi heute ungenutzt sind?
Also die Flächenanzahl kenne ich gar nicht, aber vielleicht mal so ein Beispiel zu bringen,
also wenn man diesen Mehrbedarf von diesen 400-500 Tausend Tonnen, der im Augenblick an Naturkautschuk besteht,
als Deckungslücke für die 2030er Jahre, wenn man den mit russischem Löwenzahn jetzt decken wollte,
reden wir über die Fläche von Mallorca ungefähr.
Wenn man mit Russen redet, wo der natürlich im gesamten Bereich wachsen könnte, dann sagen die,…
Mallorca haben wir.
… fällt nicht auf.
Ja.
Und man kann ihn ja auch in ganz Europa noch, in ganz Nordamerika, im Süden eben halt Australien,
Südafrika die Bereiche und dann auch Teile von Südamerika, Chile, Argentinien anpflanzen.
Also die Kultivierungsgebiete wären groß halt, um da Flächen zu finden.
Es gibt auch diese Frage immer gerne, was bräuchte man,
wenn man die weltweite Gesamtproduktion Naturkautschuk mit dem Löwenzahn machen würde?
Dann wäre das eine Fläche so ungefähr Österreich, Schweiz, also auch überschaubar.
Also wenn man das mal auf den ganzen Planeten sehen würde.
Aber das ist gar nicht unsere Intension.
Also wir wollen wirklich den Mehrbedarf decken, weil also man darf nie vergessen,
bei der ganzen Nachhaltigkeit haben wir ja auch die soziale Komponente drin.
Wir wollen natürlich jetzt nicht die Arbeitsplätze in Südostasien vernichten, das sollte man auch nicht tun.
Weil die Flächen, die da jetzt genutzt werden, die sind da und die wird man auch nie wieder zurückholen können als Urwälder.
Und damit sollen die auch weiter ihren Naturkautschuk produzieren, aber nicht mehr diesen Mehrbedarf.
Ja, mehr sollte es nicht werden.
Das heißt, die Ziele für die Züchtung liegen jetzt da drin, also ich weiß nicht, kann man das noch steigern,
dass da noch mehr Kautschuk bei rauskommt?
Also wir sehen jetzt, er kommt an die Grenze halt.
Weil das ist klar, wenn so viel Kautschuk in der Wurzel ist, dann werden die anderen Funktionen nicht mehr richtig bedient.
Dann besteht das nur noch aus Gummi.
Ja, also man sieht, wenn man an die 20 rankommt, sieht man auch schon so Wachstumsdepressionen,
also die sehen nicht mehr so richtig gut aus halt.
Okay, aber so Resistenzen gegen Schädlinge, Resistenzen gegen Trockenheit, gut haben wir schon gehört, ist ja quasi eingebaut das Feature,
aber das sind ja auch Sachen, die man unter Umständen noch machen kann
und im Prinzip ist das ja so eine Transformation von so einer Wildpflanze, die eigentlich nichts will,
außer sich gegen irgendwelche Käfer oder sonst irgendwelche Würmer zu schützen, zu so einer richtigen Nutzpflanze.
Im Prinzip genauso wie dieses Maisbeispiel, was ich vorhin gemacht habe,
auch so der Mais, der da irgendwie erst mal so vor sich ihn existiert
und dann als Nahrungsquelle duschoptimiert wird.
Ja, so jetzt kommen wir doch noch mal vielleicht auf die Reifen, weil klag ja eben schon an,
wir reden jetzt nicht von irgendeinem könnte vielleicht unter Umständen irgendwann mal passieren,
sondern man kann das heute schon kaufen.
Also es gibt tatsächlich Produkte, konkret eben Reifen, hier steht so ein Fahrradreifen neben mir.
Das ist halt einfach so ein Fahrradreifen, würde ich jetzt sagen, wenn man jetzt hier nicht darauf geschrieben hätte,
woraus er gemacht ist, hätte ich jetzt irgendwie auch keinen Unterschied feststellen können,
weil es gibt diesen Unterschied in diesem Sinne eigentlich auch gar nicht oder?
Nein, also das ist der sogenannte Urban Taraxagum, das ist so ein Trademark eben von der Continental
und die haben, das ist eigentlich nicht der erste Reifen, der gebaut worden ist,
wir haben also wirklich damals eigentlich angefangen mit PKW-Reifen, das war das erste.
Also aus dem ersten Kautschuk, den wir erhalten haben, sind direkt PKW-Reifen gebaut worden,
und zwar nicht so irgendwelche Prototypenreifen, die vielleicht irgendwie aussehen wie ein Reifen,
sondern Conti hat damals gesagt, wir bauen direkt unseren besten Reifen aus Löwenzahn.
Und den vergleichen wir dann auch mit dem aus dem Kautschukbaum direkt.
Dann sind dann, ich weiß gar nicht mehr die Zahl, es waren zweistellige Zahlen halt,
irgendwo 30-40 Reifen daraus gebaut worden und die sind dann eben halt auch diesen Herz- und Nierentests unterworfen worden.
Das heißt, sie sind einmal auf diesem Contidrom, das ist so eine kleine Formel 1 Strecke,
die da im Norden von Hannover ist, getestet worden von diesen Testfahrern auch.
Die also nichts anderes machen, als diese Neuentwicklungen von Conti dann eben zu prüfen.
Und da sind alle Tests super abgeschlossen.
War jetzt nicht irgendwie, dass ihnen die Dinger um die Ohren geflogen sind,
sondern die haben alles mit der gleichen Bravour abgeschlossen wie das Pendant aus dem Kautschukbaum.
Dann sind sie auch im Winter getestet worden irgendwo in Nordfinnland oder Nordschweden unter diesen winterlichen Bedingungen.
Da kommen wir wieder auf diesen Winterreifen zurück, wo man Kautschuk eben braucht, Naturkautschuk.
Auch da waren die Werte gut.
Und danach sind LKW-Reifen gebaut worden, also ein stückweit größer halt,
also das ist schon massiv, wenn man da so einen LKW-Reifen mal stehen hat, ganz andere Dimensionen.
Und alle diese Werte waren positiv.
Und dann sind Alterungen getestet worden, also hält der Reifen auch, UV-Stabilität
und das ist alles positiv.
Und dann kamen wir zu dem Punkt, naja was macht man jetzt?
Jetzt hat man eine Pflanze und wir konnten einen Hektar oder zwei Hektar anbauen pro Jahr.
Was machen wir jetzt?
Also zwei Tonnen Gummi.
Na, das war da noch viel weniger halt, da waren wir bei 100 Kilo angekommen oder irgendwas.
Also wenn wir doch jetzt wirklich zeigen wollen, dass das eine nachhaltige Quelle für Naturkautschuk ist, müssen wir skalieren.
Und dann kam die Idee eben auf, da haben wir damals viele Gespräche geführt eben mit Anklam,
das ist in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern oben, unter Hiddensee so geografisch.
Stadt von Otto Lilienthal, also der kommt daher, da gibt es auch ein schönes Museum.
Was ist da in Anklam?
Das ist da insofern, da gibt es eine Zuckerfabrik und ich hatte da mal einen Vortrag gehalten
und ich fand immer die Logistik von einer Zuckerfabrik wäre auch die richtige für so eine Kautschukfabrik.
Warum?
Weil die haben zentral ihre Fabrik, ringsum, so sagt man, 50-80 Kilometer Radius hat man die Felder.
Dann werden die Rüben da hingebracht.
Die haben einen großen Vorhof, wo die die Rüben hinwerfen, dann werden die gewaschen, geschnetzelt und so weiter.
Eigentlich genauso, man würde den Löwenzahn vom Feld holen, legt den irgendwo auf eine Miete,
mal in Anführungsstrichen, davor, kommt in eine Waschstraße rein, weil da ist natürlich auch Erde dran,
das sind ja beides Feldfrüchte, wo man den unterirdischen Teil dann nimmt halt.
Muss dann auch geschnetzelt werden, also das ist so ein bisschen von der Logistik ähnlich.
Und die Böden sind da genau die, die wir eigentlich haben wollten, relativ sandige Böden auch.
Und hatten dann damals damit gesprochen und Conti hat es dann übernommen und hat dann gesagt,
okay, dann gehen wir jetzt den nächsten Schritt und haben dann eben halt eine Versuchsstätte da hingebaut.
Also das ist schon recht groß dieses Anklam, das heißt /unverständlich/,
das ist eine relativ große Einheit, wo nicht nur der Kautschukextraktionsprozess,
also die Mühlen sind jetzt viel größer geworden als wir die je hatten.
Also wir hatten so kleine, die sahen aus wie eine Waschmaschine.
Kaffeemühlen sozusagen.
Ja so ungefähr.
Und das sind jetzt natürlich riesige Dinger, die da stehen halt, das hat dann schon Dimensionen, das ist eine riesige Halle.
Aber die Wurzeln müssen ja vorher noch getrocknet werden, liegen die dann einfach in der Sonne?
Nein, die werden gekocht und kommen dann direkt nass in die Mühlen auch rein.
Ah okay.
Und man braucht natürlich entsprechendes Feld.
Und dann haben die natürlich jetzt auch mit vielen Landwirten in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern dann ihre Verträge,
dass die eben halt den Löwenzahn für die anbauen.
Entschuldigung, warum muss der gekocht werden?
Diese Wurzel wird dann im Prinzip erst mal weicher als sie so ist
und dieses Polymer wird dann auch verfestigt ein bisschen.
Gummipolymer.
Ja, genau.
Also es wird noch besser durch das Kochen?
Es wird besser zu extrahieren halt.
Besser zu extrahieren, ah okay.
Und das passiert jetzt gerade.
Also jährlich wird das dann eben hochskaliert.
Und das ist auch so was, das ist schwer zu erklären, also am Anfang sagt man,
jetzt könnt ihr doch morgen schon Autoreifen bauen, und zwar als Serie.
Conti sagt immer, und das finde ich auch gut, wir gehen dann mit Reifen auf den Markt,
wenn wir auch den Markt nachhaltig bedienen können.
Es nützt uns nichts, wenn wir sagen, wir produzieren jetzt, sage ich mal, dieses Jahr eine Million Autoreifen
und nächstes Jahr können wir nicht, weil die Nachhaltigkeit nicht gegeben ist.
Und deswegen skalieren die gerade.
Und in der Skalierung fällt natürlich unwahrscheinlich viel Kautschuk an
und deswegen baut man jetzt erst mal diese Fahrradreifen daraus.
Weil man da einfach sehr viel weniger Markt oder weniger Material hat, um diesen Markt zu bedienen.
Genau und man muss es nicht wegwerfen halt.
Man hat schon ein super Produkt und macht jetzt die Skalierung und da wollte ich eigentlich drauf hinaus.
Ich kann nicht sagen, ich mache heute einen Hektar und morgen 100 Hektar,
weil irgendeiner muss das Saatgut produzieren.
Das ist jetzt bei Zuckerrübe oder bei Raps, da gibt es große Saatgutproduzenten,
da kann ich sagen, ich brauche für 100, 200, 10000, 40000 Hektar Saatgut, die sind ja darauf eingestellt.
Hier muss erst mal die gesamte Kette aufgebaut werden.
Das sind so Dinge, die man, also ich zum Beispiel als jemand, der an der Universität arbeitet, nie dran gedacht hat.
Muss ja irgendwann mal einer da sein, der sagt, ich mache mal zigtausend Kilogramm Löwenzahnsaatgut.
Und das kann sich jeder zu Hause mal anschauen, wenn ich so eine Pusteblume habe,
wieviel Saatgut da drin ist, können wir vielleicht auf eine Küchenwaage legen, da wird man sehr enttäuscht sein.
Dann kann man sich mal vorstellen, was man für Mengen da produzieren muss,
um überhaupt so viele Felder zu bauen und das passiert jetzt gerade, man skaliert.
Gehört ja auch noch eine Ökonomie dazu im landwirtschaftlichen Betrieb.
Ich meine, es muss ja auch dort angenommen werden und als Gelegenheit auch angesehen werden, das sind ja auch langfristige Entscheidungen.
Man muss Maschinenprozesse, ausgebildete Mitarbeiter etc. haben.
Man muss das irgendwie auch, sagen wir mal, in so eine Firma integrieren und ist ja auch in gewisser Hinsicht ein Investitionswagnis.
Genau. Also das war auch am Anfang so ein bisschen unser Problem, als wir mit den ersten Landwirten gesprochen haben
und das noch nicht so publik war auch.
Da haben die uns immer gesagt, wir sind doch nicht bescheuert, wir bauen doch kein Unkraut an.
Also /unverständlich/
Und das ist auch das Problem, die meisten Pflanzenschutzmittel, die wirken natürlich gegen Löwenzahn auch halt,
weil man das ja eigentlich nicht haben möchte.
Aber und das war eigentlich wirklich spannend, als diese ersten Anbauversuche waren
und auch die gesehen haben, da ist wirklich ein Markt, dann kamen auch so viele Tüftler rein halt.
Weil man musste, es gab nicht die Sämaschine zum Beispiel, wie kann ich Löwenzahn säen.
Dann hat an natürlich Maschinen, die da im Park drinstehen, ob das jetzt Rapssaatgutsäer oder irgendwas sind, ausprobiert,
aber man musste auch immer wieder mal ein bisschen was umschrauben halt.
Weil die Samen andere Größe haben?
Weil die eine andere Größe haben halt, und die Ablage eine andere ist, als das man es bei Gräsern macht.
Also wie tief die dann da rein müssen und so?
Genau, der darf nicht sehr tief drin sitzen, weil der, wenn er zu tief ist, dann keimt er nicht mehr.
Dann ist es auch von der Größe, das ist noch nicht so richtig homogen, dass alle Saatkörner gleich groß sind.
Die sind auch nicht pilliert, das kennt man ja, so Pillen eben, wo so Zuckerrübensaatgut drin ist,
die werden als Pillen abgelegt, dann gibt es so ein großes Rad, wo die einzelnen Dinger drin sitzen und abgelegt werden.
Das gab es alles nicht.
Als Pillen?
Das nennt man Pillierung, das sieht aus wie so eine kleine Pille und da ist das Saatgut mitten drin
und außen drum ist eben halt so eine Polymerschicht eben halt.
Warum?
Das ist einmal, weil man es besser ablegen kann und dann sind aber auch noch Nährstoffe da drin halt.
Ah, so ein Kickstartdüngemittel sozusagen dabei.
Genau. Ja. Und Erntemaschinen gab es nicht, keine Spritzmittel, also Pflanzenschutz.
Alles geht gegen Löwenzahn, wenn ich da so ein normales Herbizid drauf spritze, ist der auch weg halt.
Also unwahrscheinlich viele Herausforderungen gerade in der landwirtschaftlichen Praxis.
Das wird aber jetzt gelernt und wir kriegen mittlerweile Anrufe, wir haben gehört, ihr macht doch da oben und so
und wir sitzen jetzt hier irgendwo im Hunsrück(?) oder am Niederrhein oder wo immer auch,
würden wir auch gerne machen halt.
Also liegt auch viel daran, weil man diese klassischen Feld/unverständlich/,
Zuckerrübe ist ja unter Druck gekommen halt, weil ja so diese Subventionen wegfallen
oder das Zuckerrübengeld wegfällt, kommt immer wieder jetzt mehr aus Südamerika,
ich halte es für eine schlechte Entwicklung, weil das geht wieder auf die Regenwälder,
dass da Zuckerrohr angebaut wird, ist aber jetzt erst mal so.
Und deswegen suchen die auch Ersatz.
Und jede Pflanze, die wir in diese Agro… man redet gern so über Agrobiodiversität.
Also wir brauchen mehr Kulturpflanzen, außer eben nur Mais anzubauen halt oder Zuckerrübe anzubauen.
Dann die Getreide, die wir haben halt, Kartoffeln und so was.
Weil das einfach die Böden auslaugt, weil quasi immer dieselben Stoffe entnommen werden.
Das ist einmal und vor allem auch es gibt Regionen, wo ich nicht diese breite Palette mehr habe halt.
Wenn mir da die Zuckerrübe rausfällt, dann habe ich da nicht mehr viel andere Sachen
oder Roggen rausfällt oder irgendwas halt, und dann sind die heilfroh, wenn es mal was anderes gibt.
Wir sehen auch so ein bisschen einen Vorteil, also wenn man diese Diskussion sieht mit,
Insekten sterben halt, also Löwenzahn ist schon eine attraktive Pflanze für Insekten.
Wir sehen doch viele Bienen da drauf, das sieht man auch zu Hause.
Auch auf dem russischen?
Auch auf dem russischen ja.
Und man muss dann nur wieder auch aufpassen, deswegen wir haben so Stakeholderdialoge auch,
also wir haben von Anfang immer gesagt, machen wir nicht diesen closed Job,
also sitzt Conti, Fraunhofer und Uni sitzt zusammen und wir denken uns was schönes aus,
sondern lasst uns frühzeitig mit der Öffentlichkeit reden.
Also wir machen jährlich so ein Seminar, wo auch eben halt NGOs drin sind, also da sitzen durchaus BUND,
vom Bund, von Nabu Vertreter drin, denen wir die Dinge vorstellen und fragen die aktiv auch,
also seht ihr Problem oder nicht.
Und auch interessant halt, dann war das Zellaer Bieneninstitut drin und der hat uns dann gesagt,
ja Löwenzahn ist gut, gar keine Frage, ihr dürft nur nicht den Fehler machen halt,
wenn man ein Überangebot hat an Löwenzahn, dann werden natürlich die Bienen präferenziell das nehmen.
Dann ist ja irgendwann der Löwenzahn verblüht und wenn danach nichts kommt,
kann das auch negative Wirkungen haben.
Deswegen ist auch so ein bisschen der Versuch eben halt, das kann man beim Löwenzahn sehr schön machen,
der blüht also nicht nur im Mai, sondern blüht auch noch im Juni, im Juli und so weiter halt.
Man nennt das sehr blühfreudig, dieses Ding halt.
Ah, je nachdem wann er gepflanzt wird?
Nein, auch so.
Also der ist nicht so synchron wie unsere.
Hier kennt man das ja, im Mai sind die ganzen Wiesen voll mit diesen gelben Blüten.
Im Juni, spätestens im Juli ist das vorbei.
Ja.
Das ist bei dem ein bisschen anders.
Auf der einen Seite schön für Insekten, auf der anderen Seite nicht so gut für die agronomische Praxis,
alldieweil Blüte kostet Energie und man will ja eigentlich die Energie dafür haben, dass er viel Naturkautschuk macht,
deswegen wird es da auch sicherlich langfristig dann dahin gehen, dass man versucht, das alles zu synchronisieren halt.
Aber das ist alles steuerbar und da muss man sich das genau anschauen
und das ist wichtig, dass wir diese Begleitforschung haben.
Also wir haben Wissenschaftler dabei, die schauen sich an, was passiert mit Bienen, die da drauf sitzen
oder anderen, also Wildbienen vor allem auch, andere Insekten, aber gibt es auch Auskreuzungspotenzial.
Also ist das jetzt so, dass wenn ich da jetzt hektarweise russischen Löwenzahn habe,
dass das überall hingeht durch die Pusteblumen, dass also überall…
Also es ist auch eine Pusteblume?
Ist auch eine Pusteblume und das wird aber gemacht, wir haben einen Spezialisten,
den Herrn Uhlemann, der schaut sich an, gibt es Hybridisierung,
das heißt also, kreuzt der russische Löwenzahn sich mit dem einheimischen
und man bekommt neue Varietäten daraus oder wie gesagt, kann dadurch die Pusteblume irgendwo in Naturschutzgebiete reingehen
und auf einmal haben wir da überall den Löwenzahn stehen.
Haben wir nicht, kann ich direkt beantworten.
Also das liegt noch ein bisschen daran, dass diese Pflanze halt einfach nicht so diese Durchtriebskraft hat.
Kann man auch sehr schön sehen, wir haben, als wir den Löwenzahn haben wollten,
das habe ich noch gar nicht gesagt, das war gar nicht so einfach da ranzukommen,
weil diese Löwenzähne, die in so Saatgutbänken abgelegt worden sind weltweit,
also botanische Gärten, die haben alle die falsche Pflanze abgelegt, das war nicht der russische Löwenzahn.
Sind dann auch in die Gebiete gegangen eben halt, wo das mal angebaut worden ist,
und man findet den nicht, also der ist keine invasive Art, das ist uns auch bescheinigt von den entsprechenden Behörden.
Aber trotzdem wird das beobachtet halt, dass also jetzt nicht irgendwann mal der Moment kommt und man denkt,
jetzt haben wir …
Das war jetzt nicht so eine gute Idee.
Weil das ist auch so ein bisschen verrückt, also wenn man in der Gesellschaft diese Diskussion führt,
alle finden Löwenzahn so als Symbol der Ökologie, finden die toll.
Man sieht ja auch sehr oft so diese Pusteblume, aber keiner will es im Garten haben halt.
Da gibt es ja diese Ausstecher und diese ganzen Sachen halt und das sieht man immer wieder.
Deswegen muss man da aufpassen halt, dass man jetzt nicht da eben zu beiträgt,
dass auf einmal diese Pflanze invasiv wird halt, deswegen wird sich das auch genau angeschaut.
Es gibt ja jetzt auch so, das führt jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen zu weit,
aber gerade wenn man jetzt so intensiv an so einer Pflanze forscht, ist das ja vielleicht auch etwas,
was man ausprobieren kann, dass man jetzt im zunehmenden Maße Lebensmittel auch so nicht auf dem freien Feld angebaut werden,
sondern mit so hydroponischen Systemen, so quasi sich so Fabriken baut,
wo Lebensmittel gezüchtet werden.
Ist das für solche Nutzpflanzen auch eine Option, dass sozusagen jenseits des Feldes zu machen?
Also wir haben an dem Fraunhofer Institut in Aachen, also in der Mutter von dieser Außenstelle,
da haben wir auch so eine Vertical Farm stehen.
Das Problem ist einfach, dieser Löwenzahn, dieser Kautschuk, der produziert wird,
in dieser hydroponischen Kultur wird der nicht gemacht.
Das ist so, ich sage immer gerne, das ist ein Wellnesstempel für eine Pflanze halt.
Unter den Bedingungen macht sie das, dass sie schön wächst halt,
aber alle Stoffe, die sie braucht, um so ein bisschen Abwehr zu machen, scheinen so runtergefahren zu werden halt.
Also wir haben ganz ganz große Wurzeln.
Ach so, weil das Gummi ist ja ein Schutz und wenn es nichts gibt, gegen das man sich wehren muss, dann fällt das weg.
Es kann auch einfach der fehlende Kontakt zur Erde sein.
Das kann multifaktoriell sein, aber wir haben dann wirklich schöne Wurzeln, aber da ist kein Kautschuk mehr drin halt.
Jetzt gibt es auch eine Berechnung aus Amerika, die haben das wirklich mal am Computer durchgerechnet,
also selbst wenn es gehen würde, ist das Primärinvest, um überhaupt mal in Produktionsbereiche reinzukommen von ein paar Tonnen,
liegt bei 13 Milliarden US Dollar, was man investieren müsste, um die ganzen Farmen aufzubauen,
um da jährlich eine Maintenance, also diese Erhaltung von diesen Kulturen, von rund 1,3 Millionen Dollar,
und solange ein Kilogramm Kautschuk 1,30 Euro kostet, brauchen wir über so was nicht reden halt.
Also das kann man wirklich mit Pflanzen machen, das ist ja was man im Augenblick auch sieht,
wenn man mal in die Supermärkte geht, das sind Gewürzpflanzen, die natürlich hochpreisig sind,
da lohnt sich das, aber wenn ich jetzt wirklich an eine Pflanze gehe, wo der Rohstoffertrag relativ gering ist,
dann wird sich das noch nicht rechnen.
Das wird vielleicht mal kommen, wenn es mal draußen nicht mehr geht.
Also wenn es wirklich einen Klimawandel gibt, der so intensiv ist, dass wir Nutzpflanzen auf dem Feld nicht mehr anbauen können,
dann wird man natürlich diese Dinge neu überdenken.
Mit anderen Worten, eigentlich ist die Pflanze ideal gerade für Böden, die jetzt,
haben wir ja auch schon gesagt, jetzt nicht unbedingt primär für Lebensmittelproduktion infrage kommen,
aber vielleicht auch für Böden, die auch generell derzeit auch so für die Agrarindustrie so nicht im Auge war?
Also was mir sehr am Herzen liegt ist, wir haben auch so Kooperationen halt gerade mit diesen Revieren halt jetzt,
wo es den Strukturwandel gibt.
Wir haben in Zusammenarbeit mit dem rheinischen Revier, das ist noch nicht mit dem Löwenzahn,
aber da arbeite ich gerade dran, das sind ja diese Rekultivierungsflächen halt und die sind primär erst mal …
Also so Tagebauflächen.
Ja. Und wir wissen ja, die Ausstiegsszenarien wie sie aussehen halt
und es wird natürlich versucht auch, in diesen Regionen Alternativen zu etablieren.
Jetzt wäre es eigentlich aus meiner Sicht natürlich auch eine schöne Initiative zu sagen,
es gibt ja in Europa oder in Deutschland und in Europa generell und auch in Nordamerika gibt es ja keine kautschukproduzierende Industrie.
Habe ich, glaube ich, eben schon mal erwähnt und man könnte natürlich diese Regionen nehmen,
um halt so was da zu etablieren.
Das hieße, man macht jetzt nicht mehr Braunkohle als Beispiel, sondern man macht Naturkautschuk.
Man hat da eine Fabrik stehen, die Naturkautschuk produziert, hat natürlich riesige Flächen,
die da rekultiviert worden sind, eben halt die jetzt erst mal nicht für die Nahrungsmittelproduktion vorgesehen sind
und könnte da so was schon so durchaus implementieren.
Würde das auch den Böden zugute kommen?
Mit Sicherheit.
Also das ist ja auch so bei Löwenzahn, das sieht man sehr oft, das sind auch so eine der ersten Pflanzen, die kommen halt.
Bodenverfestigung und und und halt, aber auch Eintrag an Nährstoffen und diese Dinge halt.
Strukturierung von Böden, also man könnte sich so was durchaus vorstellen halt.
Und ich glaube, der Wille ist da, das zu tun und wie gesagt, wir würden dann auch Szenarien haben,
dass wir gar nicht mehr an Flächen gehen, die irgendwie mal landwirtschaftlich genutzt werden,
sondern wir würden auf vollkommen neue Flächen auch gehen können.
Mit dem Charme eben halt auch, dass man da eben eine neue Industrie etabliert,
die eben halt auch für die Leute, die da jetzt irgendwann mal eben aus der Braunkohle rausgehen
und keine Arbeit mehr haben, vielleicht da eine neue Zukunft finden können auch.
Klingt ja eigentlich alles ganz vielversprechend, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf.
Auf jeden Fall ist hier noch Arbeit zu leisten, aber die wird jetzt auch geleistet.
Diese Kooperation geht weiter und ist auch langfristig auf sicherem Terrain?
Ja, das ist was, also das ist eine eingeschworene Gemeinschaft worden halt.
Das ist schön zu sehen halt, ich sage immer gerne, wenn man mich vor zehn Jahren gefragt hätte,
was ein Reifen ist, ja da hätte ich nicht viel zu sagen können.
Wenn man vor zehn Jahren bei Conti jemanden gefragt hätte, was denn Pflanzenzüchtung ist,
wäre das wahrscheinlich auch sehr mau gewesen, was da rausgekommen wäre.
Also wir haben sehr viel voneinander gelernt, wir haben sehr viel Vertrauen aufgebaut.
Klar gibt es hin und wieder auch Streit, das ist immer so.
Gibt es auch in der besten Familie, aber das soll schon langfristig sein, ja.
Ja, dann fällt mir jetzt auch nichts mehr ein, was ich noch fragen könnte.
Eine schöne Geschichte ist das auf jeden Fall, weil es auch schön zeigt,
glaube ich, wie der Grundlagenforschungsbereich auch sehr aktiv so zum industriellen Geschehen beitragen kann,
und nebenbei auch noch so ein paar Probleme unserer Umweltzerstörungsproblematiken auch noch mit einsammelt.
Und so kann es weitergehen meiner Meinung nach.
Ja. Kann ich nur unterstützen und vielen Dank für das wirklich angenehme Gespräch halt.
Ja, ich habe zu danken.
Ich hoffe, dass wir in zehn Jahren dann auch diese Autoreifen dann aus Löwenzahn also auf dem PKW sehen und auf dem LKW,
das würde mich schon doch sehr freuen.
Aber wenn man es auf dem Fahrrad haben will, dann kann man jetzt schon zugreifen.
Da kann man jetzt zugreifen.
Alles klar, Herr Prüfer, vielen Dank.
Ich habe zu danken.
Und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei Forschergeist.
Bald geht es wieder weiter und bis dahin sage ich, tschüss und bis bald.